While many businesses were shutting down, Co-op was stocking up.
It needed 5,000 extra workers in lockdown.
Co-op Group is owned not by shareholders but by its members.
It's a different model of organizing a business,...
...one that makes its boss accountable for more than just growth.
I'd be very much assessed by the social impact that I can have in communities,...
...by how much money we can raise for good causes,...
...by where our efforts go around campaigning.
And so it's a far more deeper, richer assessment...
...than possibly a PLC CEO might go through.
In those first five years of difficult startup,...
...twice as many co-ops survive than the normal business.
And therefore it suggests to me that our way of working, our governance,...
...our accountability is a better way of doing business.
That way of working will chime with a new zeitgeist of how businesses run.